[Music]
on TV tonight it's the first live Big
Brother addiction and two female
houseguests should be baron well I
actually talked to the host Julie Chen
about who could be sent home and what's
going on with all the love in the house
I've seen it happen every year why would
this year be any different it's already
a juicy season with Julie telling me 100
microphones in 87 cameras are catching
plenty of drama
you step on everyone's toes it's done
don't talk to me Reverend and tell them
three Big Show manses you just have to
have a good gut and hope you're not
getting clay would you expect with a
theme of temptation but tonight it's the
end of the line for one unlucky
houseguest who will be booted off live
going head to head on the chopping block
Jillian a bubbly 24 year old sales rep
from Las Vegas I would say Jillian's
going home but who knows and Christmas
yes that's her real name
she's 33 and calls herself a fitness
superstar Christmas is you know a wild
card that's the one you got it there is
add and intrigue as we have news
Christmas was injured which may get her
the sympathy vote there was an accident
the house and I don't want to you know
spoiler alert the stakes are high and
some of the behavior is low and devious
it's all in pursuit of a half a million
dollar grand prize and Julie says it's
anybody's game expect the unexpected
we have many tricks up our sleeve but
one thing Julie did will out she says
the dog-walker Megan too abruptly quit
during Sunday's episode she ain't coming
back
she is not returned
[Music]
you